ready
please raise your right hand reaffirm
that the testimony you're about to give
before the committee will be the truth
the whole truth and nothing but the
truth so help you god i do
let the record reflect that the judge
has answered in the affirmative
and having met that requirement you may
now proceed with your remarks
chairman durbin
ranking member grassley
and distinguished members of the
judiciary committee
thank you for convening this hearing and
for considering my nomination
as associate justice of the supreme
court of the united states
i am humbled and honored to be here
and i am also truly grateful for the
generous introductions that my former
judicial colleague judge tom griffith
and my close friend professor lisa
fairfax
have so graciously provided
i'm also very thankful for the
confidence that president biden has
placed in me
and for the kindness that he and the
first lady and the vice president and
the second gentleman have extended to me
and my family
today will be the fourth time
that i've had the honor of appearing
before this committee to be considered
for confirmation
over the past three weeks i have also
had the honor of meeting each member of
this committee separately
and i've met with 45 senators in total
your careful attention to my nomination
demonstrates your dedication to the
crucial role that the senate plays in
this constitutional process
and i thank you
and while i'm on the subject of
gratitude i must also pause to reaffirm
my thanks to god
for it is faith that sustains me at this
moment
even prior to today i can honestly say
that my life
has been blessed beyond measure
the first of my many blessings is the
fact that i was born in this great
nation
a little over 50 years ago in september
of 1970
congress had enacted two civil rights
acts in the decade before and like so
many who had experienced lawful racial
segregation first hand
my parents
johnny and ellery brown
left their hometown of miami florida and
moved to washington d.c
to experience new freedom
when i was born here in washington my
parents were public school teachers
and to express both
pride in their heritage and hope for the
future
they gave me an african name
kitanji onyika which they were told
means lovely one
my parents taught me
that unlike the many barriers that they
had had to face growing up my path was
clearer
so that if i worked hard and i believed
in myself in america i could do anything
or be anything i wanted to be
like so many families in this country
they worked long hours and sacrificed to
provide their children every opportunity
to reach their god-given potential
my parents have been married for almost
54 years and they're here with me today
i cannot possibly thank them enough for
everything they've done for me
i love you mom and dad
my father in particular bears
responsibility for my interest in the
law when i was four we moved back to
miami so that he could be a full-time
law student and we lived on the campus
of the university of miami law school
during those years my mother pulled
double duty working as the sole
breadwinner of our family while also
guiding and inspiring four-year-old me
my very earliest memories are of
watching my father study
he had his stack of law books on the
kitchen table while i sat across from
him with my stack of coloring books
my parents also instilled in me and my
younger brother kitaj the importance of
public service
after graduating from howard university
kitaj started out as a police officer
following two of our uncles
after the september 11th attacks on our
country kitaj volunteered for the army
and eventually became an infantry
officer serving two tours of duty in the
middle east
kitaj is here today providing his love
and support as always
and speaking of unconditional love
i would like to introduce you to my
husband of 25 years dr patrick jackson
i have no doubt that without him by my
side from the very beginning of this
incredible professional journey
none of this would have been possible
we met in college more than three
decades ago and since then
he's been the best husband
father and friend i could ever imagine
patrick i love you
william patrick's identical twin brother
is here as well
along with his wonderful wife dana
also here from park city utah are
patrick's older brother gardy and his
wife natalie
and last but certainly not least
my very dear in-laws the matriarch and
patriarch of the jackson family pamela
and gardner-jackson have traveled here
from boston to be with me today
i'm saving a special moment in this
introduction for my daughters
talia and layla
girls i know it has not been easy as
i've tried to navigate the challenges of
juggling my career and motherhood
and i fully admit that i did not always
get the balance right
but i hope that you've seen that with
hard work determination
and love it can be done
i am so looking forward to seeing what
each of you chooses to do with your
amazing lives
in this incredible country
i love you so much
there are so many others who are not
here today but whom i need to
acknowledge
i have a large extended family on both
sides they are watching from florida
north carolina new jersey connecticut
new york massachusetts colorado and
beyond
i also have incredible friends three of
my college roommates came here today to
support me
and i have so many other boosters from
miami palmetto senior high school
harvard undergrad harvard law school and
all throughout my personal and
professional life
i've also had extraordinary mentors like
my high school debate coach fran berger
may she rest in peace
she invested fully in me including
taking me to harvard the first i'd ever
really thought of it
to enter a speech competition
mrs berger believed in me and in turn
i believed in myself
in the category of great mentors it was
also my great good fortune to have had
the chance to clerk for three brilliant
jurists
u.s district judge patty cerris u.s
court of appeals judge bruce celia
and supreme court justice stephen breyer
these extraordinary people were
exceptional role models
justice breyer in particular not only
gave me the greatest job that any young
lawyer could ever hope to have
but he also exemplifies what it means to
be a supreme court justice of the
highest level of skill
and integrity civility
and grace
it is extremely humbling to be
considered for justice briar's seat and
i know
that i could never fill his shoes
but if confirmed
i would hope
to carry on his spirit
on the day of his supreme court
nomination
justice breyer said quote
what is law supposed to do
seen as a whole
it is supposed to allow
all people all people
to live together in a society
where they have so many different views
so many different needs
to live together in a way that is more
harmonious
that is better
so that they can work productively
together
end quote
i could not have said it better myself
members of this committee
if i am confirmed i commit to you
that i will work productively
to support and defend the constitution
and this grand experiment of american
democracy that has endured
over these past 246 years
i have been a judge
for nearly a decade now and i take that
responsibility and my duty to be
independent very seriously
i decide cases from a neutral posture
i evaluate the facts
and i interpret and apply the law to the
facts of the case before me
without fear or favor
consistent with my judicial oath
i know that my role as a judge is a
limited one
that the constitution empowers me only
to decide cases and controversies that
are properly presented
and i know that my judicial role is
further constrained
by careful adherence to precedent
now in preparing for these hearings you
may have read some of my more than 570
written decisions and you may have also
noticed that my opinions tend to be on
the long side
that is because i also believe in
transparency
that people should know precisely what i
think
and the basis for my decision
and all of my professional experiences
including my work as a public defender
and as a trial judge
have instilled in me the importance of
having each litigant
know that the judge in their case has
heard them
whether or not their arguments prevail
in court
during this hearing
i hope that you will see
how much i love our country
and
the constitution
and the rights that make us free
i stand on the shoulders of
so many who have come before me
including judge constance baker motley
who was the first african-american woman
to be appointed to the federal bench and
with whom
i share a birthday
and like judge motley
i have dedicated my career
to ensuring that the words engraved on
the front of the supreme court building
equal justice under law
are a reality
and not just
an ideal
thank you
for this historic chance
to join the highest court
to work with brilliant colleagues to
inspire future generations
and to ensure
liberty
and justice
for all
thank you judge jackson